der Gebirgspass führt uns hinauf bis auf
1.500 Meter Höhe wir sind in
Bergkarabach hier darf nur fahren wer
eine spezielle Erlaubnis der
aserbaidschanischen Regierung hat die
Landschaft beeindruckend und schön doch
der scheint trügt in Bergkarabach tobt
schon seit Jahrzehnten ein brutaler
Konflikt wir passieren 5 Checkpoints bis
zu unserem Ziel die Stadt Schuster die
Armee azabaidschans hat den Ort im Krieg
2020 von den Armenien zurückerobert die
Stimmung ist angespannt wir treffen
er ist 1992 vor armenischen Truppen
geflohen jetzt ist er zurückgekehrt und
zeigt uns die Ruinen seines früheren
Hauses der Tag seiner Flucht hat für
immer Spuren hinterlassen
hier schauen Sie hier hatte mich ein
Splitter getroffen
und die linke Hand wurde durch einen
weiteren verletzt
direkt neben mir sind zwei Menschen ums
Leben gekommen
war 25 als er seine Heimat verlassen hat
30 Jahre lang hat er dann in Baku
gewohnt und als LKW-Fahrer gearbeitet
jetzt will er wieder in sein altes Haus
ziehen
es ist unmöglich zu sagen wie man sich
fühlt wenn man vor seinem eigenen Haus
steht
gar nicht da natürlich man muss sagen
natürlich ich werde das Haus mit meinen
eigenen Händen wieder aufbauen natürlich
kann ich
Armenier und Aserbaidschaner haben in
der Sowjetunion in Schuster zusammen
gewohnt doch nach deren Zusammenbruch
begannen die Kriege und Massenmorde auf
beiden Seiten
Berg Karabach liegt völkerrechtlich in
Aserbaidschan
1991 bis 94 eroberten armenische Truppen
dort große Gebiete darunter auch die
Stadt Zuschauer im Krieg 2020 siegte
Aserbaidschan und holte sich Teile von
Bergkarabach zurück seitdem verbindet
die Armenia in Bergkarabach nur noch
eine Straße mit dem Kernland der
sogenannte latschen
also bei Jan baut Shisha jetzt im Akkord
wieder auf
der autokratische Präsident Elam Alija
hat das zu seiner Priorität gemacht
schuscher ist das Symbol für die
Überlegenheit über Armenien
regelmäßig besuchte die Stadt mit seiner
Ehefrau Mary banalya die gleichzeitig
auch
Vizepräsidentin des Landes ist
immer dabei die Kameras des
Staatsfernsehens
das Karabach frei ist war immer der
Traum meines Vaters Haida alias und
aller Aserbaidschaner weltweit wir haben
uns diesen Traum erfüllt und das
aserbaidschanische Volk wird sich immer
an den Tag des Sieges am 8 November 2020
erinnern lang lebe das
aserbaidschanische Volk lang lebe
Aserbaidschan
bisher überwachen russische Truppen den
latschinken Korridor doch
Aserbaidschaner blockierten diesen
monatelang zehntausende Armenia kamen
nur schwer an das Nötigste Ende April
schaffte alliiert dann Fakten und baute
am Eingang des Korridors einen
Grenzposten auf ein Bruch des
Friedensvertrags von 2020 doch alliiev
hatte den Zeitpunkt mit Bedacht gewählt
Armeniens Schutz macht Russland ist in
der Ukraine gefordert und geschwächt
was die Kriege mit der Region gemacht
haben sehen wir im ehemaligen
Frontgebiet in akdam östlich von
schuscher die Schützengräben und
Stellungen sind alle noch zu sehen wo
früher Wein angebaut wurde sind jetzt
Minenfelder so weit das Auge reicht
Samir abasov sucht hier jeden Tag nach
ihnen ein lebensgefährlicher Job für den
Familienvater immer wieder kommt es zu
Unfällen aber dieses Risiko lächelt er
weg
wir sind Angst habe ich nicht selbst
meine Kinder haben sich an die ständige
Bedrohung gewöhnt das Geräusch einer
Explosion ist für sie nichts besonderes
mehr es ist wie ein Donner oder ein
Gewitter
im Frühjahr mehrheitlich
aserbaidschanisch bewohnten akdam stehen
heute nur noch Ruinen
die Aserbaidschaner werfen den Armenien
die gezielte Zerstörung ihrer Bauwerke
und Kulturgüter vor
immer wieder treffen sich die
Staatschefs beider Länder unter
internationaler Vermittlung auch
Russland möchte mitsprechen doch beim
Treffen Ende Mai in Moskau gab es wieder
keine Lösung des Konflikts
in Aserbaidschan fühlt man sich im Recht
das Selbstbewusstsein ist groß klein
beigeben möchte man nicht
das erleben wir auch bei Familie safarow
elmadin der Sohn von Mutter Sarah ist im
Krieg 2020 gefallen das ganze Wohnzimmer
ist ein Schrein für den Toten
sein Körper blieb 22 Tage lang auf den
Feldern von fisuli liegen erst am 29
oktober um 22 Uhr wurde uns mitgeteilt
dass unser Sohn gestorben ist
keine Mutter würde ihren Sohn so
verabschieden wollen eltern sollten ihre
Kinder nicht begraben
war ist wütend auf die Armenien die ihr
den Sohn genommen haben sie sei selbst
in Armeniens Hauptstadt Jere waren
geboren wurde aber in den 60er Jahren
von dort vertrieben sagt sie
Familie Safar auf will uns mitnehmen zum
Friedhof zu Elmar Dienst Grab seit
seinem Tod ist die Familie in der ganzen
Gegend bekannt el Madine hat dem Ort auf
dem Schlachtfeld Ehre gebracht so sehen
Sie das hier deswegen sagt seine Witwe
das auch ihr Sohn in die Fußstapfen des
Vaters treten soll
natürlich wird er zum Soldaten
er soll wie jeder Mann ein Soldat sein
es ist seine Pflicht sein Heimatland zu
verteidigen
wie kann eine dauerhafte Aussöhnung
gelingen zwischen zwei Völkern die sich
seit Jahrzehnten hassen töten und
bekriegen eine faire Lösung der
bergkarabach-frage wäre ein erster
Schritt
[Musik]